we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail I received last night about
Dhaka and the government shutdown and
negotiations David I'm gonna start I
have a question for you about the I was
just so wondering if you considered that
this whole shutdown was bleeding on to
something bigger like I like a bigger
deal in Trump's we didn't once that did
exchange for full amnesty might get full
funding for border security like I know
they were talking about getting five
point seven billion for different parts
of the wall but wondering if this is and
maybe leading to something bigger like
not for a year maybe a twenty or thirty
billion for full border security and
full amnesty for the dreamers and the
you know easier immigration policies and
such just you have a beer that was
pretty sweet a great compromise for both
I think yeah so I've talked about this a
little bit I would be opai's I said
before I'm against the wall but I'd be
open to allocating some amount of money
for the border wall if it did include an
actual path to citizenship a permanent
status for daca recipients the thing is
I wasn't thinking of upping the money
for the wall in exchange for that I was
thinking of lowering it like Trump wants
five point seven billion as part of a
deal in exchange for three years of an
extension for daca recipients I was
thinking of only half of that like three
billion in exchange for permanent status
for daca recipients in the United States
and maybe that's the problem with that
idea that you and I talked about
yesterday Pat which is that if it's
going to happen it's gonna have to be
for more money not for less and then I I
bail immediately if the idea is thirty
billion in exchange for that permanent
status oh yeah that that's way too much
I'm thinking maybe two or three billion
but it sounds like the idea of declaring
a government crisis an emergency that
seems to be off the table now because
it's so overwhelmingly unpopular so
that's a bit of good news out of all
this yeah if you believe that Trump
would be influenced by public opinion
which maybe he is maybe he isn't
only 7% of Americans in a new poll that
we'll cover tomorrow support holding
government closed over border wall
funding only 7% and that does indicate
that it would be politically disastrous
to declare a national emergency over
this if seven only 7% even think that a
shutdown is warranted by it but that
doesn't mean Donald Trump won't at some
point panic and declare a national
emergency anyway but good idea I I do
have a hope that if anything good comes
of this it would be permanent status for
daca recipients I just think that the
president and Democrats are going to be
so far apart as to what it would take
that it's not a very likely scenario we
have a great bonus show for you today
great stories we'll talk about gun laws
will talk about the Tokyo subway and
much much more hope to see you there